joining us now with more is the texas
senator himself ted cruz i love that
line
i'm not going to apologize for thoughts
or prayers nor will you apologize
for the right of the people to keep and
bear arms and protect themselves
and their family senator thank you for
standing up for our constitution
and the second amendment because
apparently many are not tonight and joe
biden's threatening executive action
well sean that's exactly right and and
the modern day left is
is more and more extreme they have this
bizarre antipathy
to to god and to prayers so any time
look look
all of us have had people who've lost
loved ones and then the first thing you
do when someone has lost a loved one is
you reach out and say hey i'm lifting
you up in prayer i'm praying for you
your family
i know you're hurting and and may god's
peace be with you
and the left treats that like how dare
you believe
there's an omnipotent god who could
actually love you and care for you
but but more broadly than that we see
this
cynical pattern whenever there is a mass
murder and i got to say we have had
way too many of these mass murders look
i've represented texas and the senate
for nine years now i have been santa fe
high school santa fe is less than an
hour away from my home
i was down in santa fe high school
within an hour of that shooting it was
horrific
the crazed madman who murdered those
kids
el paso the crazed racist
bigot who murdered the people at that
walmart i was there
for that dallas when five police
officers were murdered
by a radical leftist i was there for
that and i got to tell you sutherland
springs the worst church shooting in u.s
history
small town outside of san antonio i was
there the day after the shooting
in that sanctuary i saw with my own eyes
the blood and shattered glass and the
agony
and the incredible love of that
community there have been
too damn many of these and we need to
stop them
but the democrats proposal every time is
always the same which is take away guns
from law-abiding citizens that is their
political agenda every single day it
doesn't work it doesn't reduce crime
and in fact it makes it worse because it
disarms the potential victims and makes
them vulnerable to criminals if you want
to stop them
the way to do it what works is you
target the bad guys
you'll go after violent criminals you go
after felons you go after fugitives
you go after those with serious mental
illness you stop them from getting guns
and when they try to illegally buy a
firearm you lock them up
and put them in jail and back in 2013 i
introduced legislation
it's called the grassley cruz
legislation it targeted the bad guys
that directed the department of justice
to prosecute felons and fugitives who
try to illegally buy guns
the democrats in 2013 filibustered
grassley cruz we got 52 votes on the
floor of the senate a democratic senate
nine democrats voted for it so it was
the most bipartisan support
of any of the comprehensive legislation
and yet harry reid and the democrats
chuck schumer and the rest of the
liberals
filibustered it demanded 60 votes it
didn't pass
i'll tell you sean if grassley cruz had
passed there's a very good chance
sutherland springs never would have
happened
because the criminal who had committed a
felony was ineligible to buy guns
the obama air force never reported his
conviction to the background database
and when he tried to illegally buy the
gun his conviction wasn't there he was
allowed to buy the gun
and he murdered those people if brass
crews had passed they would have
prosecuted him they would
have put him in jail and he would have
been in a jail cell instead of in that
beautiful sanctuary
aren't these the same democrats all
summer long
when we were watching bricks and rocks
and
and bottles and frozen water bottles and
molotov cocktails and nearly 3 000 cops
injured
30 people killed uh let's see arson
looting the taking over of police
precincts burning them to the ground
allowing city blocks to be taken over
autonomous zones chairs
chop summer of love spaghetti potluck
dinner zones
aren't they the same ones that were
telling us every day that
these are not riots these are peaceful
protests that's what i remember from
last summer
no i think that's exactly right and the
these are are
rich liberals who have their own
security details
who say that you shouldn't be able to
protect your own family you know we had
a hearing in the senate judiciary
committee
where we heard testimony that in 2020
the rate of gun buying went up
dramatically and it went up
in particular among minority communities
among african americans among hispanics
among asian americans
and and one of the questions i asked at
the hearing i said look how much
did the riots of 2020 the antifa the
black lives matter riots
that were burning our cities that were
looting stores that were murdering
police officers
how much did that contribute and i'll
tell you the witness testimony was quite
a bit
i can tell you in houston i remember
when these riots were happening there
were stories about how
violent mobs were to come into the
suburbs and raid people's homes and i
got to tell you
in houston that would not work out well
because in texas a whole lot of the
homes people believe
in the right to keep and bear arms and
if you come after their families you're
going to meet the business end of a
firearm
and that is a fundamental right
protected in the bill of rights
do you know every year sean firearms are
used in a defensive situation to stop a
criminal
about a million times a year and the
democrats they want to take that away
which endangers you and your family
and they oppose targeting the bad guys
and the criminals
you want to stop this gun violence go
after the bad guys that's
what works and protect the second
amendment it's amazing how joe biden
thinks he can bypass
congress again we'll be following that
constitutionally
he doesn't have the authority senator
great job today thank you